Kevin can you uh you can hear me I
certainly can dan how are you good
morning man it's good to have you let me
give you the full introduction here
11-year career former goalie first black
analyst in the 91 years of the NHL and I
know you've had some comments on what's
going on black lives matter and I was
curious in a sport like hockey just what
it was like playing on it you know night
in and night out basis of what kind of
racism that you ran into yeah Dan I
think for the listeners and the viewers
more importantly hope everybody's safe
just to start off there and healthy of
course our deepest condolences to George
Florida Floyd family and others but in
saying that from my own experience it
was unique because my parents came from
beautiful Barbados in the Caribbean they
emigrated to Canada I was born in Canada
and you know what aw he meets Canadian
people and right from when I was six I
aspired to play in the league first
great miss Mar was my teacher the first
book I wrote I sketched the NHL logo on
floor board
my parents have it to this day I had
myself in goalie equipment and I knew
from then I would that was my life
school to play in the league but along
the way playing youth hockey in Toronto
for the most part at that time everybody
treated my family my sister and I well
once I got to junior as opposed to play
in US College once I got to junior in
Canada I started to see a little bit of
a different vibe from some people
because I was climbing the ranks and
that happened to be my NHL draft here so
for the most part my teammates were
great but some opposing players would
say some things like hey we have there's
five brothers that are playing in this
game why are we even doing the faceoff I
sunrises let's have a jump ball you know
that type of stuff and then in addition
to Kupa you know some fans yelling
racial epithets in the stands where my
parents would be there and my sister so
that was kind of my first kind of
encounter with that and then you know
you had some some odd knucklehead fans
around the league and there's so many
great cities that early example let's
say Philly Philly's an awesome sport
city just down the turnpike from us here
we know that it's a rich history but
what's weird is you have some people
that are cheering for Iverson AI the
answer that's our guy we love AI we love
Elton Brand and then the next night I'm
playing against the Flyers
and then some people will be yelling
racial epithets so that was part of the
challenge but ultimately Dan you know
those things are hurtful they show a
lack of class on behalf of the people
that do that but for me it was about
setting my own story living my dream
taking care of my family playing in the
best league in the world and being one
of sixty goalies on planet earth at any
given time and sometimes one on one and
being the only black one on planet Earth
so I lived my dream as a player and I'm
doing it now as a broadcast did you ever
tell management yeah there were certain
instances where you know I played for
some great managers I think all told
there's probably 15 Stanley Cup rings
between four of the general managers I
was privileged to play for and they're
not only Hall of Famers they're great
people so I've had some really great
conversations with Glen Sather who was
the architect of the Oilers during their
reign with Gretzky in the 80s also great
Lula Morello who ran the Devils here who
I played for was now running the
Islanders just to name a few
Commissioner Bettman has always been
very supportive at a great conversation
with him this morning Deputy
Commissioner Bill Daley some of the
coaches I played for have been excellent
Paul Maurice John torch Eddie some other
ones but some of them were really great
around that especially the
aforementioned
they were very helpful in they respected
me not only as a player but also as a
person they respected my family and that
one that meant a lot to me still does to
this day but when you see bananas thrown
on the ice Kevin that happened I mean we
see this in soccer it's still going on
but you're there and like how do you
react to something like that or not
react to something like that
you know what that's the thing that's a
great question I'm going to tell you why
it's basic as the question sounds Dan
you capture the essence perfectly
because we were playing in the Stanley
Cup playoffs against Montreal in 2002 I
was with the Carolina Hurricanes and
we're in the Eastern Conference
quarterfinal and you know the history of
the Montreal Canadiens that is the New
York Yankees in terms of wins and
prestige that is Manchester United and
was just something unique about playing
at Montreal as if it would be a play in
Madison Square Garden here in New York
but we lost that game I wasn't in that
we lost a game 2-1 and overtime and
after the game there was a banana
rain down the Fanta thrown at me now
here's what's crazy about this now
it's 2002 the most prestigious franchise
in the league I have family that lives
in Montreal and this happens in Montreal
so and we lost the game by the way let's
just add that to it so we get in the
locker room you know I'm a little bit
upset about it of course I just think
it's the ultimate human disrespect and
fortunately our PR guy at the time is
still there with the Carolina Hurricanes
now Mike Sondheim I mentioned Jim
Rutherford who was our then GM was the
GM of Pittsburgh and Paul Maurice was
our coach and coaches wouldn't pay they
couldn't have been any nicer and my
teammates couldn't have been any more
supportive now the other part of your
question is how did I react I reacted I
was very patient
I was very diplomatic I was pointed but
I was I was very diplomatic in how I
answered that and how I responded to it
and here's the challenge that I found
with that and a lot of athletes will
tell you this and a lot of people will
tell you this too is the perpetrator
often they do the act then number two
they want to govern how you do or don't
respond if you can or can't respond
three and four if they choose to like
your response or not so that's kind of
unfair you know it should never happen
in the first place I think that's a
lowest form of class and you know that
you talked about soccer and I love
soccer I love all sports I have friends
in every league around the world we you
know I've been to Syria Gabe's in Italy
twice but I think the biggest challenge
and I've seen MLS games here in North
America but I think the biggest
challenge is all the governing bodies
have to have a zero-tolerance policy for
fans employees and players and it has to
be a safe place for everybody in the
venue and every sporting venue around
the world talking to Kevin weeks he's a
former NHL goalie spent 11 years in the
league now working for the NHL Network
their lead analyst your thoughts on
Bubba Wallace and I don't know if
there's parallels and I don't even want
to I don't want to make that leap but I
I'm curious if you see parallels
I don't want to tell you or ask you if
you see it or tell you if you do do you
see any parallels with what Bubba
Wallace is doing in NASCAR
yeah for sure I mean just based on the
demographics of NASCAR and you know I
lived in the southeast for a good part
of my career you know I played in Miami
I played in in Tampa I played in
Greensboro North Carolina when I was in
the minors and as they just mentioned I
played in Raleigh for the Carolina
Hurricanes and Leake so I know how I
know the history of NASCAR I know how
passionate the fan base is and how
passionate the fan base has been keep in
mind Brad Daugherty as you know had been
a voice of NASCAR for years long after
his days in the imba in his days of
being a Tar Heel playing at UNC but I
would say this I certainly understand
what he's going through I do
I understand it's an isolating feeling
at times and he's living his dream he
aspired to be a NASCAR driver he's
become one he's one of the best in the
world at his craft but here's another
thing that I do see too
I do see some of his competitors and
fell a racer stepping up and some of
them have stepped up and supported him
which is great to see you know we do
have a lot of people of color that dude
like NASCAR and quote unquote
non-traditional fans like we would have
quote unquote non-traditional fans for
the NHL as well but it's it's a tough
road when you're one of one at times it
can be a very very tough road but I
applaud him for what he's doing I
applaud him for having that courage I
applaud some of his fellow drivers for
also stepping behind him and here's the
thing Dan you know you've had so much
success in your career you've been
around as long as you have I always say
that sports should be connective tissue
and sports can and and typically as when
we're at our best it's transcendent
there's very few things in the world
that can transcend like sports music art
culture food but at the heart of all
that is people it's people one-on-one so
whether you're from Murphysboro whether
you're from Greensboro if you're from
Talladega if you're from Tallahassee
that doesn't make you any more supreme
or any less than anybody else everybody
should be made to feel safe and welcome
colin kaepernick I don't know if he
wants to play and then now you have
people who are spokespersons who are
saying hey we should give him a chance
now well nothing's changed with Colin
Kaepernick other than the times are
changing
I'm wondering about it feels like
tokenism to me Kevin that nobody wanted
him now let's bring him back and like
why not last year or the year before
your thoughts on Kaepernick what does he
have to lose if he comes back in your
opinion well first of all I think and
you know this to again just based on
your experience I think anytime you're
doing something that's unique or that
hasn't been done before and even if it
is positive in its spirit it's not
always met with the most appreciation
now look at the great Jordan MJ I'm an
MJ guy to the bone and fortunately I've
had a chance to meet him and playing
some of his golf events but they banned
his sneakers like think about that they
banned their Jordan when it first came
out and I'm not trying to trivialize
this around a sneaker but the sneaker
was so transcendent and so was he and
then that transcended the sport think of
the different people from various
backgrounds that grew up loving the
sport because of him so if you look at a
guy like Colin Kaepernick it was seen as
being robed some people saw it as being
extreme it wasn't well received by a lot
of people and quite frankly clearly with
time sometimes time has a way of
reframing the way in which we see and
feel about things and I think that's
kind of the case where he's concerned
from a perception standpoint because the
atmosphere right now is such that we see
what's happened and maybe more people
are more attune and in tune to what's
happening based on coronavirus they're
able to process information from the
people I've spoken to then we see this
is crazy we see we never knew this was
happening week C I played with you I
never knew it was to this extent Wow I'm
so sorry what can I do to help and so
for cap now I think the biggest thing
for him and you you asked it off the top
a does he want to play if he genuinely
wants to play well then I always
maintain there should be an opportunity
for him to play because not every single
and NFL quarterback on a roster is
better than him right now and I think a
lot of that lies with whether or not he
wants to play and then from the owner
standpoint just to continue to be
open-minded and know that if an if and
when he's a fit for a specific team and
he can come and make your team better
then why not I don't look at it as a
tokenism I just look at it as an
opportunity to for people to reframe
maybe what they thought before and
that's not unique to the owners we've
all had to do that how much pressure do
you think you'd be under if you were
playing now to take a knee during the
anthem uh I think you'd be if it were me
specifically hockey oh yeah oh I think
there'd be tons for sure I think there'd
be tons but I also think that there
would be less than there would have been
six months ago for the same reason you
know given the pandemic people have more
capacity to be more empathic more
compassionate they're not necessarily
commuting a lot of people are working
remotely from home and I just feel like
the human capacity seems to have
expanded some and it needs to expand a
lot more quite frankly but I can tell
you Dan there's so many NHL people
players coaches agents owners I just had
a great conversation with Commissioner
Bettman this morning but so many
different people in fans that I've never
met before that are sending messages of
support yeah I just wonder in that sport
wait yeah I wanted one of that sport
though Kevin if if you took a knee I
don't know if fan asking about now yes
less so now than six months ago for sure
for that very reason you know for that
very it's great to have you on yeah well
I appreciate you so much but a long time
man thanks for having me yes thank you
Kevin we appreciate your time good luck
that's Kevin weeks Foreman HL goalie NHL
lead analyst there